Pennywise was famously first brought to life
by Tim Curry in the original It mini-series.
If the filmmakers behind the new It movies
were going to make their mark, they needed
a Pennywise for the ages.
Here's how Bill Skarsgård rose to the challenge.
Skarsgård began developing his take on Pennywise
well before he actually started shooting any
scenes.
He took plenty of inspiration from Stephen
King's original novel, which helped him understand
the balance between Pennywise's evil, cosmic
origin and its more recognizable clown form.
But he had very few visual cues to draw from
as he first began to flesh out what made the
creature tick.
This created certain challenges in designing
the character, particularly in terms of his
voice, which in the film ranges from childlike
to nasally and wavering to outright monstrous.
"Popcorn!
Is that your favorite?"
"Uh-huh."
"Mine too!"
For Skarsgård, that voice and its many facets
could not fully come into his head until he
saw what Pennywise actually looked like.
He told Collider:
"It was really when we did the full make-up
test and see what the character would actually
look like … My first test with the prosthetics
and makeup was where I saw what the character
would actually look like with me in it.
That's something I needed to explore to [discover]
what this thing would sound like."
With makeup artists, digital effects artists,
costumers, and director Andy Muschietti's
own designs for the character, Skarsgård
had a lot of help getting into the look of
Pennywise.
Pennywise's demonic grin, for example, is
created by Skarsgård drooping his lower lip
down so that it almost comes to a point.
That's not a prosthetic or digital effect,
but simply something he's always been able
to do.
"Can we see that?
Do you mind — just for that camera right
there."
"Which one?"
"Number three?"
"Yeah."
When Muschietti was designing the character,
he had the idea that sometimes one of Pennywise's
eyes would wander, and told Skarsgård that
he would add the lazy eye in digitally in
post-production.
Skarsgård explained that he could do it…
and revealed that he could trigger his own
lazy eye.
"What are the chances that the actor that
you cast can do that practically?"
Because Pennywise takes the form of a clown,
his costume was obviously always going to
be a key part of the overall look, and for
that Muschietti turned to costume designer
Janie Bryant.
Rather than take the more modern circus clown
approach of the miniseries, Bryant went for
something a little more timeless, with Victorian
and even Elizabethan influence to give it
a sense of history and even immortality.
In shaping the costume, Bryant added peplum
around the waist, a ruff at the neck, and
other assorted blossoms of fabric to create
a certain effect.
Bryant explained:
"I wanted it to have an organic, gourd or
pumpkin kind of effect.
It helps exaggerate certain parts of the body.
The costume is very nipped in the waist, and
with the peplum and bloomers it has an expansive
silhouette."
The exaggerated effect created by the costume
gives the already tall Skarsgård the look
of having impossibly long limbs, and the tightness
around his torso suggests the body of an insect
scuttling around the sewers of Derry.
Bryant also emphasized a high waist and kept
the pants short to add to the character's
childlike qualities.
In preparing for the role, Skarsgård watched
the 1990 miniseries adaptation of It, featuring
Tim Curry's generation-terrifying performance
as the original Pennywise.
He also made the decision not to specifically
study Curry, because he knew his Pennywise
needed to be different.
To that end, Skarsgård brought together an
intriguing and diverse array of influences.
He studied footage of animals to help him
get into the more predatory aspects of the
character, and found himself particularly
drawn to hyenas and bears as influences.
He also drew inspiration from another iconic
clown of cinema, Heath Ledger's Joker in The
Dark Knight, though Skarsgård acknowledged
there were limits to that comparison, since,
quote, "Heath Ledger's Joker is rooted in
the real; you can break down the psychology."
He acknowledged, however, that the same rules
didn't apply to Pennywise, since he's not,
quote, "a real person."
“Sticks the blade in my mouth.
'Let's put a smile on that face!'"
Both Skarsgård and Muschietti have emphasized
the "childlike" quality of Pennywise, and
to help bring that into the performance - particularly
when Pennywise lunges at his victims - Skarsgård
took inspiration from his little brother.
He told Rolling Stone:
"I don't know if you've seen kids run like
this, but they move their arms way too fast,
and it looks really, really funny.
And I just loved the way my brother ran as
a kid.
It was just out of sync.
So I incorporated that into the character,
and you get this really explosive effect.
It's really unsettling when it happens."
"I'm not afraid of you."
"You will be."
Though Muschietti was determined to use practical
effects as often as possible in the film - even
allowing Skarsgård to do quite a few of his
own stunts - Pennywise is still a shapeshifting
monster from another dimension, which meant
that, sometimes, stunt doubles and digital
effects were going to be the way to go.
Digital effects came in handy when it came
to designing Pennywise's expanding mouth with
its rows of teeth.
According to Rodeo FX visual effects supervisor
Arnaud Brisebois, the effects team designed
a digital "rig" that allowed them to animate
Pennywise's terrifying mouth with as much
detail as possible.
Brisebois told SYFY:
"The teeth rig was all hand-animated.
We basically modeled the teeth all individually
or as clusters that could be grown and oriented
in any way."
The digital effects team was also called upon
for the sequence in which Pennywise crawls
out of the fridge in addition to, of course,
the final showdown, in which the character
is constantly changing shape.
Brisebois explained:
"Basically what they did was bring in all
the stunt performers into a gym, and they
learned the choreography and they motion-captured
this.
We built really quick CG assets for all the
characters, including Pennywise, and we planned
out all his transformations and the action."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.